bonjour Elena veloshin vous êtes notre
ancienne correspondante à Moscou alors
est-ce une crise de l'armée des
paramilitaires ou est-ce une crise de
régime alors je dirais plutôt le dernier
et encore crise de régime c'est
peut-être un peu faible pour 15 pour
ceux qui en train de se passer qu'est-ce
qui se passe c'est que clairement le
chef de ce qui apparaît aujourd'hui
comme une armée parallèle au sein de la
Russie a déclaré la guerre au
commandement militaire russe il a
annoncé le fait qu'il voulait mener un
coup d'État militaire sans le nommer
ainsi c'est ce qu'il dit en tout cas
lorsqu'il dit nous allons faire cette
marche de la justice pour sur Moscou
pour éliminer Sergio le ministre de la
Défense et Valérie guerassimov le chef
d'état-major des armées il dit aussi que
une fois les opérations terminées les
institutions du pays reprendront leur
fonctionnement normal c'est-à-dire que
il prévoit en fait de saisir toutes les
institutions du pays ainsi que les
forces de sécurité maintenant par
rapport à Vladimir Poutine hier dans son
discours il a offert en quelque sorte
une porte de sortie à Vlad Poutine en
disant que les responsables de du
désastre de la guerre en Ukraine de la
mort de dizaines de milliers de Russes
de Russes c'était Sergueï chouï et
Valérie guirassimov ce matin Poutine
avec son discours le Chef d'état-major
de l'armée russe ce matin on Vladimir
Poutine dans son discours qui attardait
d'ailleurs à venir il a pris beaucoup de
retard et il n'a duré que 5 minutes il a
pris position en quelque sorte en disant
déclarant qu'il y avait gagné Prigogine
était un terroriste que c'était un
traître et que l'armée russe allait tout
faire en fait pour rétablir l'ordre de
ce fait Vladimir Poutine dit que
indirectement il n'accepte pas
évidemment la main tendue de Prigogine
mais on a du mal à comprendre comment
après avoir après avoir déclaré qu'il y
avait gagné Prigogine était un
terroriste la situation pourrait évoluer
autrement que dans une confrontation
armée entre l'armée russe ou en tout cas
ceux des militaires qui resteront
fidèles au régime et l'armée parallèle
de yevgani Prigogine qu'il clament être
25000 hommes cela peut être plus la peut
être moins plus d'ailleurs non sans
doute qu'il l'aurait dit ou encore que
il peut aussi ne pas vouloir dévoiler
l'intégralité de sa stratégie mais
cette confrontation armée elle est
aujourd'hui inhabitable d'ailleurs il y
a gagné prigogne ce matin dans sa
conversation semi privée avec le
ministre adjoint de la défense Younes
sur cette base militaire de Rostov on
l'a entendu dire qu'il y a déjà eu des
morts et vu la réaction de yefcoff on a
peu de doutes quand au fait que cela ne
peut qu'être vrai la ligne apotine il
affirme que la réponse sera très ferme
face à cette menace mortelle c'est les
termes qu'il emploie nous ne laisserons
pas cela se reproduire mais de quel
moyen dispose actuellement Vladimir
Poutine est-ce qu'il peut mettre au pas
prégriger une Wagner actuellement il
dispose de son armée il dispose de son
armée et de et non et de ses services de
sécurité lesquels services de sécurité
d'ailleurs ont dû l'avoir un peu
mauvaise puisque ils ont aussi été
directement mis en cause par il y avait
gagné Prigogine dans son intervention
d'hier pour avoir pillé cette région du
dombases que Vladimir Poutine prétendait
pendant défendre depuis 8 ans contre un
génocide des ruissofuns du bombasse il y
avait une prigogne à démonté en bloc
tout ce mythe hier et il a mis en cause
les services secrets russes donc on peut
s'attendre aussi que les responsables
des services secrets russe ne soient pas
très contents de ces déclarations
du soutien de ces hommes je disais que
ça peut être plus ça peut être moins que
les 25000 qu'il annonce en tout cas il a
derrière lui son armée ça c'est
absolument certain il a aussi récupéré
le vice-ministre de la Défense en la
personne de Michael de Médine sauf donc
il a récupéré des cadres très haut
gradés de l'armée russe et il a préparé
l'opinion des combattants des soldats
russes désillusionnés des abusés par
cette guerre pour très nombreux d'entre
eux depuis les mois que cela dure il a
préparé l'opinion en disant moi je vais
vous offrir mieux je vais vous offrir la
victoire donc en fait il s'est adressé à
la fois au combattant russe et à la fois
à la direction de l'Etat R pour dire au
combattant vous allez arrêter d'aller
mourir à la guerre sans munition sans
arme sans Giler par balle comme vous
l'avez fait depuis des mois parce que il
faut bien être conscient que il pryogène
ne parle pas de cesser à la guerre en
Ukraine il parle d’aller renverser le
pouvoir et de revenir en Ukraine pour
continuer cette guerre parce qu'il
considère comme il l'a dit que l'Ukraine
est peuplé de russe donc ça il faut pas
penser que il prigogne prévoit de mettre
un terme à l'opération dite spéciale
mais en tout cas je pense que son
discours était très séduisant pour les
militaires il est arrivé jusqu'à Rostov
sans que l'on entend de parler de de
combat à la frontière alors que hier il
y avait des informations comme quoi la
frontière entre la région de donuts
occupée par la Russie et la Russie avait
été fermée donc on peut raisonnablement
penser qu'il y aura un certain nombre de
militaires qui ne voudront pas mourir en
confrontant les hommes Prigogine et un
certain nombre d'hommes dans la
hiérarchie militarus qui pourrait aussi
vouloir lui prêter allégeance est-ce que
l'armée russe elle est unie derrière
Vladimir Poutine du côté de l'armée
russe maintenant je parle de l'armée
russe quand je dis ça je parle de l'AR
c'est à dire les officiers et les
soldats la grande question maintenant ça
va être de savoir qui se rallie à qui en
fait comme dans tout coup d'État qui se
respecte ça va être la lutte des clans
la lutte des clans et des allégeances
est-ce que les services de sécurité vont
rester derrière le président ou est-ce
qu'ils vont rejoindre le camp mutin etc
etc au sommet de l'État est-ce qu'il va
y avoir une scission une fissure dans le
premier cercle de Vladimir Poutine qui a
été entièrement aussi mise en cause par
Virginie Prigogine la hiérarchie
militaire etc les généraux aussi parce
qu'on a commencé à voir sur les chaînes
télégram des généraux et un général en
tout cas hier qui a appelé à maintenir
la légence à Vladimir Poutine il était
ce matin sur cette base de Rostov qui a
été finalement prise par priorgine les
gouverneurs certains dirigeants de ces
régions occupées déjà du crâne on dit
qu'il maintenaient leur soutien à
Vladimir Poutine quand en est-il des
autres gouverneurs tout ça ça va être
c'est quelque chose qui va évoluer dans
les prochaines heures mais clairement
cette
ce qu'on peut appeler selon moi cette
tentative de coup d'État elle va se
jouer aux allégeances comme c'est
toujours le cas d'ailleurs merci
beaucoup Elena wolochine pour votre
analyse merci à vous